you are what you consistently do the
problem for people watching this video
for you your problem is that you know
where you want to go you know what you
want to accomplish you actually even
know the habits that you need to do
you're just not doing them consistently
you get motivated you get inspired you
get pumped up something happens in your
life that then makes you want to go and
drive further Harder Faster let's go and
then you fall off the track you go back
to the old ways you go back to your old
habits and then you don't end up
accomplishing your goals even though you
know you're capable you know what's
possible you know you could do it you
have done versions of it in the past but
you're not consistent on it that's the
problem and that's what we need to shift
in this video because until you get off
that Loop you're going to keep running
the same cycle over and over and over
and over again knowing that you're
capable of more knowing that you've got
the potential hard to accomplish amazing
things to serve to make a lot of money
to be the person that you want to be
knowing that that's possible but them
never actually accomplishing it we're
gonna fix that in this video need
motivation watch a top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael and I
make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
my husband Evan Carmichael and our take
on his top 10 rules for Success enjoy
so I've got a a model the four stages of
personal development before stages of
personal growth and the first one is the
haters and the haters are the people who
hate their own life and this is most
people most people don't actually love
their own life if you really dug down
and analyze people you ask them about
themselves and how much they love their
life most people will not love their
life most people do not have positive
self-talk when they look in the mirror
most people over judge themselves over
criticize themselves and know that
they're not living the life that they
could be living that's most people most
most of the world hates their life and
it shows up especially in America in in
depression rates and suicide rates like
people are not happy
people are not happy and as a result
they're in a lot of pain and as a result
of that they they hate on other people's
ideas if you're thinking why so many
people will tear down your ideas and
tell you why you can't do it
because they are in a lot of pain
themselves
because they maybe took a shot at their
life their dream life and it didn't
didn't happen it didn't they didn't make
it so now nobody around them can be
happy either right
this is the problem I'm trying to solve
you know I'm trying to move people from
the land of haters because I believe
people are good you know I believe
people are good people are good people
want to serve you're built to serve you
want to serve you want you want to help
people are at the core of good and yet a
lot of people are negative because
they're in a lot of pain so that's step
one and that's probably not if you're
watching this video if you're subscribed
to this channel that's not you you're
not the hater but you know probably a
lot of people who are haters
and you can join me on my mission to to
save them to serve them to help them to
shift them to move them forward to
realize that their dream life is
possible rule number two motto success
whenever you don't know what to do the
best thing you can do is model success
find the person or the people who've
done the thing that you want to do learn
how they did it apply it to your
situation so you can achieve similar
results and get to your goal otherwise
you're constantly bouncing around
between idea to idea to idea to idea
constantly trial and error trial and
error trial and error and you might run
out of time and it might actually get
too late where if you can model success
the the biggest shortcut to success is
to model
find the people who've done it
understand how they did it apply it to
your life this is the thing that changed
my life
I I quit on my business partner I was 19
years old
maybe 20 at that point I quit on my
business partner I was just tired of
things not working I was tired of the
business being so slow and sluggish and
and
any results and making no money I was
tired of it I was ever before that that
I applied myself to I got a result and
here I was trying trying every day
trying showing up to the same place
showing up to my business partner's
living room every day working from this
dining room table every day and just not
getting results
and I was tired of it so I quit
and then I woke up the next day and
realized I don't want to quit I can't
quit yet I can't quit it's I'm gonna
regret this but I can't keep doing it
the way I'm doing it and so
the genius moment out of pure
desperation
was
somebody has done this before I asked
myself who has done this before who has
built a software company before who's
done it I'm trying to solve this problem
I don't feel like I'm an idiot although
I kind of feel like it like an idiot
right now because I'm trying so many
things but I know I'm not stupid
somebody's done this before it can't be
this hard who's done this
and that's where it thought of Bill
Gates who started Microsoft in a
he's just one of many he could have been
anybody in software he was just the only
person I could think of at the time
and I learned his story and found out
how he did it and applied those
strategies through him with sort of
partnership so I thought okay let me get
some Partnerships and I got my first
deal I've said for thirteen and a half
thousand dollars a little while after
and
that changed everything for me that
changed the business that that made me
stay in it that gave me hope that made
me feel not worthless that made me feel
like things were possible that gave me
growth in the company and it also gave
me a strategy for the rest of my life
and that whenever I don't know what to
do the best thing to do is to model
success rule number three take action
the biggest problem
with wannabes is you're watching a video
or you're going to an event and you
think that that's the work that's not
the work that doesn't matter until you
actually do something watching this
video doesn't mean anything unless you
actually take action on it right nothing
changes in your life until you actually
take action on it watching this video
going to somebody's event Listen to
Somebody's podcast might get you
inspired
right it might get you thinking about
what's possible
about where you could go
but it doesn't actually lead to you
doing anything until you do something
always push in every video I need you to
take action I need you to take action
you got to do something rule number four
be Mission driven as entrepreneurs we're
Mission driven right you want to solve a
big problem you want to make a huge
change in the world so remind yourself
of what the mission is and how grateful
you are to be on this path even if
you're not where you want to be yet
you're not doing what you want to do
fully yet but you never are there you
never when you hit that goal you you
want a bigger goal I think that's great
so you're on your journey
and you're much more fulfilled on that
Journey than you used to be compared to
who you used to be compare your life to
where you were five years ago or ten
years ago
the awareness education you've gone
through the the purpose the heart that
you've now discovered and tapped into on
a deeper level
for me I'd be thinking about
helping entrepreneurs
I get to every day wake up and help
entrepreneurs I get to make videos I get
to make content I get to influence
people I get to I get to try to
help 18 year old Evans out there who's
struggling with their first business
right
for you what's your big mission
and how can you tap into it and feel it
and it may not have to take too long to
do it but just close your eyes and
actually feel that you touch somebody's
life
again it may not be the scale that you
want it's never the scale you want but
you touch somebody's life
if one person left a comment on your
video if one person left a thumbs up on
your post you touch one person's life
tap into what that feels like
that you had a meaningful impact on them
today also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five inject positivity
dating I would have been the guy who 10
years ago would have thought that's not
possible for me I'm just introverted shy
kid who
just is not a type A personality and
doesn't like networking and will never
meet these people so step one
consume their content even if you never
meet these people just having them
around you daily allows you to start to
shift and start to think like them
allows you to start to adopt their
mindset because they're saying things
that are different than the people in
your life John Ashraf is saying
something different than your parents
right he's thinking a different way than
your friends he's thinking on a higher
level than a lot of the people probably
in your life right now
and so the more that you're around that
virtually by watching videos even if you
never meet him the more you start to
think bigger to have more ambition to
believe that it's possible so part of
your daily routine must must must be
to consume the content of the people who
inspire you to want to be bigger that's
why I make this espresso videos where I
make all of my content on all of my
channels but if it's not my videos if
it's books if it's podcasts
something it's got to be daily though
just like you brush your teeth daily you
need to inject
positivity and belief daily from people
who are doing more than you right your
brush your teeth helps you with your
dental hygiene we need to work on our
mental hygiene it's really really
important because the the mental hygiene
will take care of itself in a negative
way based off your current environment
if you are if you are just constantly
battling negativity around you or
small-mindedness around you and there's
nothing that comes into your life that
feeds you with hope and positivity and
inspiration in the sense that you could
do more if there's nothing in that in
your life right now then you won't go
off and do it and so step one is to just
be around the content every single day
in micro doses every single day my new
routine right now is I go for a walk in
the morning and it's about 40 to 45
minutes in the morning and I I watch my
own videos I watch my top 10 videos
while I go for the walk so this morning
I was watching uh Lewis Howes video and
a garyvee video that I made for my
channel and every time I do it I pick up
something new it's a fantastic way to
start my day if you could start your day
every day with garyvee or Lewis Howes or
John assarath or Oprah or Elon Musk or
whoever your life will change
it's why I do these espresso videos I
want to give you the shot of espresso
every morning your life will change if
you start your day every day with the
people who inspire you they will pull
you up and you don't notice it on a
day-to-day basis but if you look back a
week a month three months six months a
year if you did it every day for a year
holy cow you will be a totally different
person run number six change your
environment there is always a way there
is always a way there is always a way
there is always a way there is always a
way when you feel stuck when you feel
hopeless when you feel like the world is
against you and you've got big ambitious
goals remind yourself there is always a
way there is always a way
entrepreneurship is always about how
resourceful you are instead of the lack
of resources this is where people get
cut up you wish you had more money you
wish you had a different education you
wish you had different parents you wish
you lived in a different country you're
so focused on the things that are not
going right in your life instead of
focusing on what can I do with what I do
have there is always a way wife has to
go shopping on filming day great I'll
film in the car with Timo hi Teemo high
five good boy
he's so cute uh business shuts down my
dance studio closes down because of
covet great Move online like there's
always a way I was telling my friend
Mark about
uh how I got the Honest Company for my
book your one word so I don't know three
four five years ago I don't know how
long ago how long ago when did Euro one
come out it doesn't matter
um I wanted to get the Honest Company
because they built their business around
their one word honesty and they were you
know 100 million dollar plus company
wanted to interview them there was only
one big problem I didn't know them I had
no connection in and I I wrote in and I
didn't hear back
and they really really wanted the
company so there's always a way remind
yourself there's always a way so what I
did was I wrote to TechCrunch and
TechCrunch at the time was the biggest
you know blog slash website slash news
site for the tech industry and I said
hey
I messaged the the managing editor who I
did not know either right just cold out
of the blue said hey I'm writing a book
and I'd love to do an interview with the
Honest Company
and if I did an interview with the
Honest Company would you publish it
we're going to talk about these topics
uh and he said yes
I just interviewed the managing editor
out of the blue and he said yes great
now I can go back to the Honest Company
and say Hey I want to do an interview
with you for my book and for TechCrunch
and that got me in the door
right and that then that led to me doing
the interview and flying to California
and meeting Christopher gavigan who's an
amazing human and doing the interview
and getting my book done
and so I didn't know the Honest Company
I didn't know TechCrunch I had no
Connections in
but you remind yourself there's always a
way and that's how you do it you find a
way
what can you do with what you do have
right now how can you be a resource how
can you be an asset how can you help the
people around you so that you can move
closer to accomplishing your goals as
well so how do you do it you know it's
easy to say great Evan uh you don't
understand me I'm stuck in the situation
right now how do I get out of it
everybody's against me I tried a million
I tried everything I tried everything
and it's not working how do I get out of
it it's a couple things you need to do
number one if you are stuck kind of in
the middle of it if you are stuck
feeling overwhelmed feeling it's not
possible feeling
just you've tried everything and you're
gonna give up
step number one is you have to take a
break from where you are right now
go outside go for a walk breathe
meditate because when you're in when
you're in the lowest of the low
me saying be more resourceful there's
always a way you can't actually hear it
you're not ready for the message yet
because you're too low
this is why a lot of us when we're
trying to help other people the people
around us and telling them you're going
to make it you can be great they can't
hear it because they're too low so you
have to get them back to normal State
you have to get yourself back to a
normal state so that comes from some
getting outside your environment right
now go for a walk get some fresh air do
some breathing meditate pray whatever
you need to do to get back to a normal
state so you're not a depressed human
but you can actually be open and
receptive to a message rune number seven
be an overachiever I'm here making
videos for you because that's part of my
routine you know I'm recording this on a
Tuesday every Tuesday I make videos
every Tuesday I make videos every
Tuesday I make videos every Tuesday I
make videos
I've made videos
feeling sick I've made videos with no
voice and I held up signs I've made
videos with a concussion and a broken
neck I make videos that's the difference
between an achiever and a high achiever
is that you show up when everybody else
would give you a break when everybody
else would say take it easy when
everybody else would say you're pushing
too hard everybody else says you're too
obsessed
you say no I'm committed to my goals I
committed to making this happen
because you are what you consistently do
we tend to try to over correct things if
you have a goal of eating a certain
number of calories or sticking to a
certain weight and you go and you binge
one day we tend to try to over correct
to say that's it I'm going on a 24-hour
fast you know I'm just not going to eat
anything for 24 hours or if your
business you let yourself down you don't
deliver you don't promise you don't
follow through on the Promises you say
you're going to make videos for YouTube
and then you don't do it and then the
next day you wake up I'm done with that
I'm going to make 80 videos today or
whatever the number would be we tend to
try to do too much in the short run
and that's not where the gains are made
right you could go to the gym and have
an amazing session
but if you're not consistently showing
up to the gym you're not going to get
the results that you want same thing for
the gym of Life the gym of business the
gym of of your mindset it's what you do
consistently every single day and that
can sometimes be boring
and that can sometimes be that you're
you're chasing the wrong thing you're
doing somebody else's routine instead of
your own but if you want to be a high
achiever if you want to show up for
yourself for your family for the people
around you for your customers the people
who know you can serve you want to show
up as your best self every day for them
the key is that you stick to your habits
real number eight be off value try to be
a person of value
being a person of value means what does
this person care about and how can you
help support it so if you're trying to
be a person of value to me what am I
what do I care about right now you know
the easiest thing to do is look at my
Instagram bio look at my Twitter bio
look at the things that I'm promoting
right now right now if uh right now I'm
talking about build to serve a lot it's
still something I care deeply about
right now I'm talking about movement
makers I'm talking about brand lytics
these are the programs that I'm
launching that I care a lot about so how
can you help me with that
what is John Ashcraft launching go look
at his Instagram bio his Twitter bio
what is he promoting right now that's
what he cares about right now to be a
person of value you want to be the
person's chief goal officer what do they
need right now what are they promoting
right now what are their goals right now
and then finding some way to help them
even if it's just being the best person
in the comments
right I have an amazing Community you
guys are amazing
it's what makes me want to keep making
content is because of how fantastic you
guys are and there are some people who
watch the videos and then never leave
any any comment the comments guys there
are some people who watch your video and
leave a comment and then there are the
special few who watch a video leave a
comment but then we'll also comment on
the other comments not in a promotional
way not just saying hey check out my new
channel I've worked really hard on it
let me know sub for sub but in uh in a
encouraging positive optimistic way in
just trying to cheer the other people on
and supporting them
those people are extra special and there
are there are some people who
I would do the best that I could to try
to support them I get hit up every day
with different promotion opportunities
hey Evan can you link this up can you
shout me out can you check out my
business plan and it's usually a no
because I don't even know who you are
but there are other people who have
brought so much value to my community
that I would I would do my very best to
try to help them because of how much
they've helped me even though they may
not have ever bought anything that I've
done just because they were so valuable
in the community
right so that's your goal your goal is
to be a person of value to be the chief
goal officer and then be a person of
value to them and their community so
they start to recognize you rule number
nine be the change if you don't like
something in your life
you can change it
this is why we become entrepreneurs
because we don't like something that's
going on in our lives in the in the
world you know the people around us we
don't like the way something is done
and we're committed to change it that's
why entrepreneur is going to solve all
the world's major problems we're not
waiting on government we're not waiting
on big corporations it's us we're gonna
we're gonna sell the problems you you
are going to sell the problems if you
don't like something
when most of the world is stuck in
complaining and blaming and mediocrity
and unhappiness and excuses and I'm too
old that I'm too young and I don't have
the resources and blah blah blah well
most of the world is stuck in that
you're off saying I'm gonna make a
change I'm gonna make that happen and
it's just the mindset shift that you
have to make and keep and sustain on a
daily basis because it's so easy to fall
back down into limited thinking into
fixed mindset into mediocrity to feel
like I can't do this maybe maybe it
can't happen maybe it's not for me maybe
I'm not the person maybe I'm not good
enough maybe I don't belong maybe it
works for other people but not for me
right it's so easy to go back to that
zone
but if you don't like something in your
life or your community or the world
you can change it be the change you want
to see in the world that's you you can
make that happen and Rule Number 10 the
last one before our special bonus Clips
is Bill 18. where do we learn to be
great managers you don't learn it in
school
you'll probably not be a great manager
at the beginning so I think the best way
to get going is to actually hire
somebody part-time the first person I
hired was for one hour a day
one hour a day I hired them for one hour
a day one they were better at at the
thing it was doing database stuff than
than I was so it freed up an hour and a
half of my time every day because he was
better at it than I was you could do it
faster and two it also got me used to
managing somebody on a small scale
before being fully responsible for them
before I was their entire income and had
to learn how to be a good boss a good
leader a good manager
good Mentor good coach
I could I could play
on a smaller scale and develop the
skills and so I think people wait too
long because they feel like they have to
have a giant budget you could hire
somebody for one hour a day
you know instead of buying
Starbucks
you know I don't know how much it's cost
five bucks four bucks whatever
right instead of buying Starbucks every
day
you get two coffees that's
eight to ten bucks
you hire somebody for 10 bucks an hour
to do that thing for you
one hour a day that frees up your time
to go do other things
so I want you to start being more
resourceful to try to find other ways
through instead of thinking I'm by
myself I'm all alone I can't do it
there's a famous expression that goes if
you want to go fast go alone if you want
to go far go together
you have to build a team your mission is
too big your purpose is too big
to make your dream happen
you have to focus in on your Michael
Jordan level ability and to spend more
time doing it to stop spending time on
the things that don't produce value and
that you don't have a lot of interest in
and to start thinking about how can the
people around me support me better and
if they're not going to support me how
do I find people who will
because your purpose is too important
I've tried everything you haven't even
come close to trying everything how many
things have you tried
20 there's a million things you can do
you have not even come close and don't
use that as a beat yourself down that's
a push forward to say there's a million
more ideas inside me there's a million
more ideas inside me that I can use to
accomplish this goal there is always a
way remind yourself make it your Mantra
put it on a t-shirt there is always a
way and you are going to find it your
chances of success go up in direct
proportion to your ability to one pick
the right things to work on and then two
focus on executing those things it's so
easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love dreaming up new ideas and
chasing these different projects but if
you look at a typical entrepreneur
you'll see that so many of their
projects start and stop and start and
stop and you take something 10 through
or 50 through or sometimes even like 80
through but unless you're willing to
take it to 100 you're not going to get
the results you're not going to get the
fruit of your labor because you're just
planting a whole bunch of seeds
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you're never watering it
right if you want to grow a plant you
got to plant the seed you got to care
for the soil you got to add nutrients
you got to water it daily it's got to
have enough sunshine you got to look
after that Seed where most entrepreneurs
they don't they're starting to stop it's
starting to stop and starting stopping
and you never actually get to where you
want to go people talk about
diversification you need to diversify
you need to diversify and while that's
really great as an investment strategy
if you don't know what you're investing
into it's good to have a big portfolio
of different things so that if one thing
doesn't do well something else is doing
well but it really sucks is business
advice because if you're trying to do 10
different things at once they're all
going to be mediocre they're all going
to be below average because you're going
up against people who are doing that
full time and have their focus on it and
so it's much better as an entrepreneur
to one pick the things that you want to
focus on right and then two actually
focus on it do that work Andrew Carnegie
was once the richest person in the world
and he had a great quote saying how now
he likes to put all of his eggs in one
basket and then you watch that basket
carefully right it's only a major risk
if you're not watching the basket if you
if you take your eye off the ball you
start looking elsewhere and then
something happens to your industry right
and so being the expert being the best
at what you do will always yield more
results more value more money to you
than being okay at 20 different things
be the best at one thing Focus if you
have to get motivated every single day
then you are in the wrong business if
you are in your business because you
thought it was a hot opportunity or a
path to make some quick money get out
immediately shut it all down you can't
sustain motivation for that business
don't start a podcast if you don't love
talking or interviewing with people
don't become an influencer if you have
nothing to say don't start a daycare if
you don't love kids it's not worth it
and you're never going to win the work
itself needs to be motivating most days
You're Gonna wake up and have a pile of
crap to deal with and if you don't love
dealing with that crap you will get
crushed by someone who does enjoy
dealing with that crap the trick is you
need to do work that you love that other
people think is crap that's the secret
so looking at my channel as an example
this YouTube channel has grown from 7
000 followers subscribers to 1.7 million
in a matter of four and a half years and
I love the climb and I love passing
people on the way and I love the
competitive Spirit of it and I know
there's still so much room to grow but
sometimes I secretly hope that the whole
thing goes away so just so that I can
start and do it again I'm just short of
sabotaging myself although I have taken
some some risks recently if you look at
my channel last month or two months ago
I did some major changes that did not
work I bet everything on going down the
premiere Direction just because just
because I wanted to have some variety
just because I wanted to take a big bet
and it tagged hard and it was my worst
subscriber gain in in years
and I love it
I love it I mean I don't love that I
lost but I love I love pushing I love
trying to get better I love climbing I
love trying to find a new way to be able
to go and build and get better and I
think you have to love the climb I'm I'm
just short of massively sabotaging
myself and and closing down the whole
thing just to start over but I love the
climb that much it's why I loved
Instagram I'm going hardcore Instagram
right now halfway through the year I had
six or seven or eight something like
that thousand followers and now now I'm
at almost 80 000 followers but still
posting six times a day and by going
live five times a week and by making
three to eight to twenty stories a day
and doing igtv and all that stuff I love
the climb I love it I love when people
look at my YouTube channel and say you
have 1.7 million subscribers but you
only have 6 000 followers on Instagram
like what are you doing you're a joke I
love it I love it I love it I love
looking at everybody who's ahead and and
having the ladder to climb up again I
love it all the people who I pass on
YouTube are all crushing me on Instagram
and I love it so much and it's not doing
it only to beat somebody else it's just
a competition I like the competition I
like figuring things out I like I like
the hustle and the grind to try to win I
don't like being number one I like
chasing down number one chart your start
what you do in the first 15 minutes of
your day matters chart your start have a
plan of action most people wake up like
an accident most people wake up they're
tired you pull out your phone you start
looking on your email and what are you
doing when you're looking at your email
or looking at social media you're
responding to other people's emergencies
like you wake up you're tired and the
first thing you do is you start
responding to other people's emergencies
I want you to control the first part of
your day chart your start understand
what it is that makes you come alive
understand what is the action it helps
you feel bold creative Unstoppable we've
all had it you've all had moments where
you have bold courageous and Unstoppable
what led to that reverse engineer
yourself what led to you feeling bold is
it watching a video is it reading a book
is it having a conversation is it doing
a meditation is it taking your dog out
for a walk is it cut in the grass like I
don't care there's no judgment I don't
care what the thing is that makes you
feel bold and courageous and Unstoppable
I just want you to do it daily I want
you to start your day with intention
most people don't start their day with
intention and that makes a difference
between the people who achieve success
and the ones who don't and so chart your
start figure out the thing that makes
you come alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible and put that into the first 15
minutes of every day if you did the
thing that made you feel bold courageous
and Unstoppable in the first 15 minutes
of waking up every single day
not every day will be amazing but I
guarantee you that your life will look
unrecognizable from where you are right
now chart your start willpower comes
from setting goals and keeping those
commitments to yourself when you set a
goal and you complete it you build more
willpower you are teaching yourself
you're training yourself that you are
the kind of person who sets goals and
sees them through and finishes them
which gives you greater willpower to go
off and take on bigger and bigger and
bigger goals but when you set a goal for
yourself and you don't follow through
you don't complete it you're teaching
yourself you're wiring your brain that
you're the kind of person who doesn't
have a lot of willpower you're training
yourself that you are the kind of person
who does not follow through who quits
when it gets tough so that's why it's so
important that you are very careful
about the goals that you set for
yourself because once you set a goal you
have to finish it you have to follow
through because that will change your
perspective of yourself if you finish it
and you do it willpower grows if you
don't finish it and you quit willpower
drops so here's a quick example for my
life I was driving to Boston I drove
there with with my wife with my film
team we decided we'd go for the weekend
it was a long drive to get the boss how
long was the Nina eight hours ten hours
how long was the drive something like
that eight hours it was late we got in
super late we got in at what two in the
morning one in the morning something
crazy after an entire day of me driving
I'm not sleeping in the car I'm driving
doing the whole leg myself driving the
team I arrived super late everybody's
going to bed and I had set a goal for
myself that I was gonna run for 30
minutes a day I was gonna run for 30
minutes every day that was my goal that
was my commitment to myself now
we get there it's late everybody's going
to sleep it would have been very easy
for me to go to sleep it would have been
very easy for me to let myself off the
hook and say it's okay it's late you
know I'll do it tomorrow I'll do double
tomorrow it's late it's no problem it's
very easy for the people around me to
say don't worry about it Evan like it's
late you could you could do it tomorrow
everybody will let you off the hook
when everybody else will let you off the
hook and you want to let yourself off
the hook that that moment exactly
precisely is where you develop or lose
your willpower because when it's easy
when your calendar is perfect when
there's no interruptions when you have
all the time in the world to do
something then you do it it's easy it
doesn't build your willpower you don't
feel great about yourself you if you win
a race against three-year-olds you don't
feel great you're not cheering that
Victory but when it's hard
when you don't think you can do it when
everybody's saying don't worry about it
when you feel like you're at your your
Wit's End when there's every excuse and
every reason in the world why you
shouldn't do it and then you still do it
that's when you build willpower it's
when it's difficult and you do it that
you build willpower and so I did my run
at one in the morning and whatever time
it was and it was a brutal run it was
not my best run I did not burn a lot of
calories it was not my Peak I'm I'm
tired I'm gassed I'm doing my run
and even though I didn't get a fantastic
physical benefit from it and even though
the next day I woke up and was more
tired compared to the people on my team
because I slept less
I'm giving myself pats on the back I'm
giving myself High pods like crazy I've
just built my willpower I've just built
my credibility with myself I've just
built my respect and confidence
internally because I did the thing that
I promised that I would do when it got
hard that's the difference that's how
you build willpower and if I had to give
advice to somebody to have success in
any field not just entrepreneurship in
any field you look at the people who
have the most success in any field they
enjoy the process and too many people
are attached just to the outcome if you
want to make a blockbuster hit if you
want to make a successful movie you have
to enjoy the process of making movies as
an entrepreneur if you want to have a
successful product you want to have a
great service that's making a lot of
money you want to have a huge business
whatever you define as huge or
successful then you need to enjoy the
process of the work that you're doing on
a day-to-day basis and not everything is
going to be amazing you're going to have
down days but net net you have to enjoy
what you're doing you have to wake up
and look forward to the day that is
ahead and too many entrepreneurs are
spending 80 to 90 percent of their time
doing stuff that they're not good at
that they don't want to be good at that
they hate because they feel they need to
do it to grow their business and only 10
to 20 of their time on the stuff that
they can be genius level at and you will
not have success in any Endeavor if
you're only spending 10 to 20 percent of
your time
or less on the stuff that you have the
potential to be the best in the world at
and that you enjoy if your goal is just
to make a lot of money and you'll do
whatever it takes just to make that
amount of money you'll never get there
because you don't enjoy the work
where the secret to success is enjoying
the day-to-day grind because it doesn't
feel like a grind it feels enjoyed I
think it's really important for
entrepreneurs to understand where your
threshold is of how much crap you could
take from other people how much
negativity how much feedback and
criticism that you can take without it
impacting your psyche or your self-worth
I think in general as an entrepreneur
you need to be prepared to get a lot of
crap a lot of negativity a lot of stuff
thrown at you and yes it's easy to say
don't care what other people think but
understanding what your tolerance level
is and where you kind of fit on that
Spectrum can really help you design the
rules so that they're in your favor so
as an example this is a guy on my team
who doesn't handle criticism as well you
know I'm a lot more comfortable in the
uncomfortable where he can bounce around
a lot more he'll be on top of the world
like this is great and then a negative
feedback comes in and it really impacts
him hardly and and then the positive one
comes in and he jumps back up and so for
someone like him you can't design as
much risk as much negativity or
potential negativity so you gotta take a
safe path up where for me I'm more
comfortable in the uncomfortable I know
that eventually Something's Gonna work
out and I know that at the beginning of
any project it's going to be
rough that it may not work out that
we're gonna get some criticism and so
I'm more willing to jump all in and play
in that field even though it's painful
at the moment because I know the faster
I get to that pain the faster we're
going to come out the other side I want
that feedback and criticism negativity
as soon as possible so that I can make
it better better for you better for me
better for everybody and so
understanding what your tolerance level
is of emotional stability how much you
can take from your friends and your
family and your customers and your
audience and the people watching you
before you break and then be able to
play just below that limit because you
can't just play Super safe because
that's not going to make you happy as an
entrepreneur but knowing where your
limit is and playing just below it so
that it's uncomfortable it's painful but
you're still going to be able to get
through it you already know what you
want to do you're letting the opinions
of other people get in the way of you
taking action people are not afraid of
failing they're afraid of failing in
front of other people you will sing all
day in the shower but you won't get on
the street quarter inching because
you're embarrassed of the judgment and
what you need to do is inoculate
yourself against the judgment and learn
to take action on your ideas because the
alternative is a life filled with regret
you have to decide at what point are you
going to take ownership for where you
are in life like at what point do you
decide my goals my ideas my dreams my
ambitions are important enough to me
that I'm willing to risk failure I'm
willing to risk embarrassment I'm
willing to risk having to go tell my
friends that it didn't work out because
this is my path
because otherwise I never get to do the
thing that I want to do
at what point are you gonna decide to
step up and say I need to do this for me
I need to know it may not work out I may
be embarrassed but I need to know I
don't want the rest of my life to sit
around wondering what if what if what if
people put too much faith in the tools
it's not about the tools it's not about
the tools that you're using it's not
about the suit that you're wearing it's
not about the car that you're driving
it's about you at the end of the day it
comes down to you I was asked to do a
Roundup of different entrepreneurs of
what your favorite tool was to help you
build your business and they asked me
and they asked 30 other people what is
the tool that you love most that helps
drive your business forward
and I was the only one who didn't want
to give a tool everybody listed their
tools and I was at the end of the day I
was posted at the very bottom the tools
don't matter stop blaming the tools
and tools are important don't get me
wrong I love using tools I think
YouTube's a great tool I think cameras
are a great tool I use tools every
single day in my business to help spread
my message and help my company grow but
it's not the Reliance on the tools this
is where I think a lot of people fall
down I had an entrepreneur a friend of
mine
come to me and says what tools do you
use for your calendar how do you keep
track of your to-do's because she had
tried using a notebook and using
Evernote and using OneNote and using all
sorts of different tools using her phone
everything
and nothing was working so it's like you
know what the problem is not the tools
the problem is you right the tools can
help you go faster but if you don't have
the mindset if you don't have the
ambition if you don't have the drive if
you're not putting in the work then the
tools will never save you and I think
people have an over Reliance on the
tools and that's my biggest problem with
it the tools can help you do that last
20 but it's 80 you it's 80 the hustle
and the hard work to get really good at
the thing and the tool can help you go
further I see tools as like pouring
gasoline on a fire you need to have a
spark you need to have a fire to get
something going and then the tool the
gasoline can help it explode
but if you just pour gasoline on wood
nothing's going to happen I think the
same thing about suits and cars I think
a lot of people think you wear a suit
now you're going to be successful suit
doesn't mean anything
clothing is an expression of self not a
place where you get your self-worth
somebody with no suit on could go in and
close a sale because they are who they
are they are confident they can close
that sale where somebody who's only
deriving Confidence from their suit will
never win if you want to succeed as an
entrepreneur you need to work both hard
and smart you need both everybody who's
had massive success did both forget
about trying to work a four hour work
week forget about passive income yes you
can make a little bit yes it might be
supplemental income to help you along
your journey but if you want to do
something impactful you want to have a a
big change in the world you want to
really be somebody special and have a
ripple effect out from you you gotta do
both you gotta work really hard
look at whoever your heroes are
whoever it is that you look up to
they didn't get there by having things
handed to them
and they didn't get there by trying to
create passive income or work four hours
a week and I love the four hour work
week book there's a lot of principles
you can use in there except the fact
that when you are committed to something
and you love it you got to go all in on
it stop being lazy lazy people don't
change the world lazy people don't have
a huge impact I want you to have a huge
impact
and so hard work is just your ticket in
hard work alone is not the answer
there's lots of people who work really
hard
and they never rise up they never reach
their potential right you can work
really really really hard as a cashier
but if you're not thinking on a bigger
scale and you're not working smart as
well then you'll just continue to work
really really hard as a cashier and make
whatever a cashier makes and that's
where you stay
hard work does not guarantee your
success but there is no success without
hard work period it doesn't exist show
me somebody who you really look up to
and really respect who hasn't put in a
ton of effort hard work and smart work
to make it happen
and so I think if you are just looking
for shortcuts if you're just looking for
ways to make that passive income or ways
to work four hours a week and then spend
the rest of the time lying on the beach
you're being lazy and you haven't really
tapped into the thing that you love
doing because I can tell you you get
tired of lying on the beach you may not
agree because your life sucks right now
because your work sucks right now
because you're just trying to escape but
people want to do things that have
meaning
after you've escaped your life and you
spent a year on the beach you're gonna
get tired you're going to get bored
you're going to do something that fills
you up we want to contribute human
beings want to contribute we want to
feel like the work that we're doing
matters and we like to work we like to
feel like the activities that we're
filling up our day with mean something
to somebody else
so you've got to find that and when you
do you don't want to just work four
hours a week it fills you up you want to
do it a lot it doesn't mean you're
spending 24 hours a day doing it you got
to find the balance for you
but when you find the work that you love
you want to go all in on it
you want to keep going because it fills
up your soul
so you've got to work hard and you've
got to work smart it's the only way to
succeed as an entrepreneur when I was 20
years old I missed my shot because I was
scared and I vowed never to do it again
I was in Paris I was on vacation I was
in university and I'm sitting here with
my map outside your Notre Dame cathedral
in Paris and a girl comes up and asks me
for directions but she was a French girl
and it didn't twig until later that why
would a French Grill be asking me for
directions
in English
didn't really make sense right and then
I thought you know what I should ask her
out if you see what she's doing tonight
should take her to you know ask her out
for coffee or dinner or something see
what she's up to but I was afraid I was
afraid to do it I was afraid to do it
and I let her walk away because really
was I was afraid of rejection and As
She's Walking Away the Notre Dame is on
a river and I'm on one side of the river
as she crosses over to the other side of
the river
and I was so upset at myself I was so
upset that I didn't take my shot I was
so upset that I didn't try at least try
and what I did was ended up taking a
picture
and as I took the picture she actually
walked behind one of the market stalls
and I didn't actually get her picture
it's fine so I had this beautiful
picture of this French you know
Riverside and what I did when I got home
I was still upset about it so I blew the
picture up and I put it on my wall I was
actually trying to find the picture to
show you guys but I couldn't find
anywhere in my files I blew it up though
and I put it in my wall so I'm at
University I blow it up and put on my
wall everybody who walks in
ask me about the picture
and it just looks like a nice beautiful
French scene but I didn't tell anybody
what it really represented to me why it
was really so important and I looked at
that picture every day because the next
time that I had to take my shot I wanted
to go out and do it I didn't want to be
afraid I wanted to conquer my fear and
say yes
and this served me really well a year or
so later when I had to make
the really tough decision do I take this
job that I always wanted I had these
high paying job opportunities 80 100 000
starting salary with the companies that
I really wanted to go at or continue
with my startup that was failing I was
making 300 a month The Logical practical
safe easy thing to do would have been to
take the job it's what I thought I
always wanted so my friends one is what
you're supposed to do coming out of
University I didn't want to live with
the regret of not knowing what happened
with my business and looking at that
picture daily reminded me to take my
shot the next time it comes around and
so I gave myself a year to say I'm going
to push off those jobs they'll still be
there in a year even if it's not those
jobs it's some other job I'm going to
give this a shot I can deal with the
failure I can deal with the rejection I
can deal with that not working out even
though that's a really kind of
short-term intense pain when I can't
deal with is the regret of not knowing
because that's not some short-term
minimal pain that's forever
if I chose not to focus on my business
and I took that job I would forever look
back on that moment and think what if
what if I just tried a little bit harder
what if I gave it a little bit more yeah
you know but it wasn't working I wasn't
getting results but what if I gave it a
little bit more I did not want to live
with that regret and I'm sure you've had
moments in your life too when you didn't
take the shot when you had an
opportunity right in front of you
and you didn't go for it
like Eminem says if you had one shot one
opportunity to seize everything you ever
wanted
would you take it
and that picture on the wall helped me
take my shot and I hope sincerely
that the next time you get your chance
at something that you don't shrink down
that you don't say no out of fear that
you don't say no because you find some
practical reason why you can't do it
that you take your shot and if you've
had those moments that you regret
where you wanted to take your shot and
you didn't
give yourself a visual reminder like I
did in my room
to say this is not happening again
next time
I'm going to take my shot
I hope you take yours rejection is part
of life as an entrepreneur you were
going to get rejected over and over and
over and over again it's just part of
being an entrepreneur and being a
business the first thing you put out
won't be very good people will hate on
it people give some constructive
criticism as well people will say no
because they don't know you trust you
like you and so you won't get those
first deals it takes a lot of time to
build up a business and make it
successful and even when you've gotten
to that point where you're feeling happy
and you're bringing on a team and
building the business you're still going
to get rejected constantly it's just
part of life as an entrepreneur and so
if you can't handle that it's going to
be a really hard Road for you to be an
entrepreneur I think the way to get
through rejection there's two ways to do
it one is to use rejection as fuel kind
of like what Jack ma did like I got
rejected 10 times by Harvard one day I'm
gonna go teach there right when they're
gonna go speak there they use that as
she was like you turned me down I'm
gonna show you I'm gonna beat it I'm
gonna come back and be the teacher there
right you turn me down for this deal on
gonna go get a deal 10 times as big
right so that's one you can easily you
can use rejection as fuel to help you go
off and do something bigger and and
motivation to I'm going to prove them
wrong the second way is just to forget
about it just get used to it that's more
what I do I don't really use rejection
as fuel it doesn't really bother me when
somebody turns me down or when a new
series doesn't work
I was trying to think when I Was
preparing for this video what's the
recent rejection that I have
because there's been so many but none
really stick out as being super
memorable the one that I came up with
was I tried a new series on the weekend
a while ago about the best of
Kickstarter and it was a new series that
I was testing of showing different
Kickstarter ideas that I thought might
be helpful for you and that video didn't
do as well as I would have liked didn't
do as well as other videos and we're
probably gonna kill that series
but that's okay like I've killed tons of
series it happens all the time on the
channel and I couldn't even tell you all
the series that I've killed because they
didn't perform you guys rejected them
it's okay I just moved past it and so
either one you have two strategies to go
for use the rejection as fuel to say I'm
gonna show you
how wrong you are and prove it to them
or just forget about it get used to it
it's gonna happen just part of the game
and you move on and just think about the
next thing that you can go off and build
use either one of those strategies but
don't get stuck in the rejection fear is
normal as part of what makes you human
you would not be human or you'd have
some crazy condition if you never felt
fear I think the people who say Don't Be
Afraid aren't giving you practical
advice
be afraid feel the fear and then step
into it and do it anyway and the more
you get used to taking on those fearful
projects that you're scared of the
stronger you'll get the more resistance
you'll get the higher tolerance you'll
get to do bigger better Bolder better
things I think the trick though is
spotting the fear
here's what I think happens to most
people there's some opportunity that
comes along
there's some moment that comes along
whether it's with a client or meeting
somebody or an event something comes
along that you're afraid of you're
afraid of doing it it's going to stretch
you beyond what you've ever done before
and then what you do is you rationalize
saying no
I don't have the money to go to that
event
I'm too busy to go and do that thing
right now you find the reason why you
can't go and do it you rationalize it
but really deep down the reason is
you're just afraid and until you spot
the fear until you understand that it's
really just the fear then you're never
going to solve the problem
so step one is understanding
when there is fear step two is then
stepping into it and doing it anyway and
a lot of this stuff is just so
subconscious you know we as human beings
are kind of trained to when we're afraid
something's going to go wrong if the be
safe and so it's trying to catch that
subconscious action and proactively
change it so an example for me when I
was starting my YouTube channel
my agent
would tell me you have to go out and do
videos in public I want you to go out on
the street and make your video in public
my natural reaction
was
fear but I didn't catch it initially it
the gear won't be as good in public you
know I can't control the light settings
I'm going to be bouncing around with the
camera it's not going to be a great
experience for the people watching why
would I do that I'm rationalizing a
reason why I don't have to do it or
really I'm just afraid right you could
solve all those problems and he told me
stop being afraid and just go out and do
it you cut through it and let me see my
own fear
and so I did it and when I first went
out and filmed in public I took out it
was my phone or my camera I don't
remember and I'm walking down the street
and then the postman is there so as soon
as I see the postman
I quiet down and I can put the camera
away
just walking normally
and then when the postman leaves
I'm back to filming
and that time I noticed like I'm I'm
doing it because
I'm afraid and I got pissed okay next
time
I gotta speak up next time I gotta do
better and so I went out
and forced myself to go and do it again
and I was walking past and there were
these construction workers and instantly
again the the Panic sets in like people
are watching construction workers like I
know they don't really even care about
me and what I'm saying what's happening
on the street
but I forced myself through it
it was awkward it wasn't great I think I
had to redo it again anyway but I I took
the step
I got better at it I recognized the fear
and I jumped into it and now to the
point where I'll make videos walking on
the hall and make videos when I'm at
Disneyland Disney World you know I'll
make videos in the streets of anywhere
and there's still a moment even now
after how many videos I've done there's
still a moment of who's watching
I think it's natural and normal it's not
as strong as it used to be and more
importantly it doesn't limit me from
doing the thing that I want to do
and so spotting the fear
and not rationalizing it away and not
just doing what your subconscious always
does that keeps you down where you are
is so important
being truthful that the reason why you
said no
or you're not taking this opportunity
just because you're afraid and the
answer to saying no should never be
because I'm afraid
you want to re-jig your system so
whenever that's the answer because I'm
afraid to do it now you have to do it
most entrepreneurs aren't patient enough
most entrepreneurs end up losing their
business they end up shutting down
because they think it's going to happen
in a couple months or even six months or
a year and really it's going to take
them four years five years before they
hit their Mark they don't have enough
patience they don't allow enough time
for momentum to build up and they quit
and they end up going back to a crappy
job that they hate and maybe never ever
take a shot to get an entrepreneurship
because they feel it's not for them well
really they missed out you missed out on
your destiny you missed on creating
something amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now I believe in patients in
the macro I believe in patience and
knowing it's going to take a long time I
also think inpatients can serve you
greatly but that's in the micro that's
in the daily the impatience of did I do
my best today did I do my best today can
I do better can I drive more can I drive
harder and knowing that even if I give
my best every single day it's still
going to take time
it's still going to take a number of
years for something to happen I want it
to happen as soon as possible I'm going
to drive and be impatient as crazy to
get it going but I know it's going to
take time too it's embracing both that's
when you start to win I look at my my
YouTube my Instagram my social media
strategy YouTube 7
000 subscribers four years ago 1.2
million subscribers now four years by
making videos every day every day and
I'm impatient as anything because I want
it to be amazing I want to make every
video better than the last and looking
for all the hacks and SEO and thumbnail
strategies and title strategies and all
of the stuff that we're supposed to do
right I'm on top of it and I know that
it's going to take me four years to get
there I know it's going to take me a
while to get to my next 2 million five
million 10 million I look at Instagram
follow me on my Instagram Journey I'm
starting from nothing you can see how to
build it up from zero I had eight
thousand followers many of you already
have more followers than I do on
Instagram but I'm gonna win I'm gonna
pass people I'm gonna get mine because
I'm gonna make daily consistent content
three to four times a day for four years
I'm gonna be impatient as anything and
that the post today has to be amazing
has to be something that I want to show
my grandkids right that's the intent
every time I create anything I want my
grandkids to watch this video I want
grandkids to watch the next Instagram
thing that I put up it's the best that I
can come up with in the moment and I
know it's going to take me four years
maybe three years maybe two years but
it's not gonna take me two months
I realize it's going to take working
hard and working smart together always
if you are not happy in life it's
because you're not serving enough I
believe that humans are good
99.99 of humans are good there's a tiny
little fraction of a percent of people
who enjoy giving harm and hurting others
because they have some chemical
imbalance but apart from that people are
good and we are connected to each other
your highest purpose in life will come
from helping others but the next
question becomes how how do I do it how
do I find my higher purpose how do I
know what I'm supposed to do how do I
get direction I'm going to give you the
three-step process that I call the
purpose planner that will give you the
clarity that you're looking for I break
it down into your who your why and your
how let's start with the who your who is
your one word most important core value
everybody has a core value if you're a
human being you have a core value that
you believe in more than anything else
and when you understand who you are when
you understand your single most
important core value then you're less
likely to be swayed by other people
you're less likely to live somebody
else's version of your life because they
have Clarity and you don't when you do
not have Clarity you end up chasing
everybody else's Clarity you end up
doing their version because they have
certainty and you have no idea what
you're doing it's like you're walking on
quicksand and you're constantly sinking
and you know there's something greater
for you your one word your most
important core value is the rock that
you stand on when the rest of the world
is crumbling around you so for me it's
belief I one word is belief that's what
I stand on if you love believe you're
going to be a huge fan of this channel
because I talk about it in some form in
every video every video should ooze
believe if you hate believe you're
probably gone by now you hate my channel
and that's okay go go do your thing
somewhere else you need to figure out
your who you need to figure out what
your one word most important core value
is that becomes the lens through which
you see your entire world and attracts
the goodness into your life step number
two is your why why do you do what you
do now I'm a big believer that your
purpose comes from your pain that
whatever your most painful moment it was
in life whatever you struggled with the
most growing up in life whatever moment
in life you felt the most worthless as a
human being
your highest purpose your greatest joy
and satisfaction will come from helping
people who are currently feeling the way
that you felt who are currently facing
that situation that you were in that you
hated the thing that you would never
wish upon anybody else in the world lots
of people are going through that thing
and if you can step in and help those
people that's going to be so filling up
your soul I can't even explain it to you
for me my one word is believe that's my
who my why is I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur I hated my life I was
struggling I was making 300 a month I
felt worthless as a human I felt like I
was bringing no value to the world and
that was massively frustrating I felt
alone and I didn't know what to do
that's why I love helping entrepreneurs
I love believing in entrepreneurs why
entrepreneurs could be anybody I could
believe in anybody believe is at the
core of who I am it's my one word most
important core value but I could be
believe it in anybody and I do and I
love it but entrepreneurs hold that
special spot for me and the startup
entrepreneurs not the ones who are
already making tons of money I love them
too but I resonate donate so much more
with the startup entrepreneurs because I
remember what it's like eating at
McDonald's and only being able to afford
french fries instead of an entire meal
so your why your purpose comes from your
pain figure out what that most painful
moment was for you and it's hard because
entrepreneurs we like looking and being
optimistic and looking forward and being
positive but it's in that pain that your
answer actually is find out what that
most painful moment was your why your
highest purpose will come from helping
people who are currently facing that
right now and then step three is the how
so how are you going to do it there's a
lot of ways you can help people who are
in that situation so for me break it
down the who was my one word is believe
the wise helping entrepreneur's purpose
comes from my pain now how do I help
entrepreneurs how do I believe in
entrepreneurs is that there's a ton of
ways that I could be believing in
entrepreneurs so the example I use of is
if you are moving your office and you
need my help to rent a moving truck and
to help you carry your desks and all of
that stuff I love the end result of it I
love that now you have this great office
where you can build a business and have
it flourish and I'll probably say yes to
helping you do that especially if you're
a close friend and but I don't love the
process of moving
I don't love the process of packing up
boxes I don't love the process of
setting up cables and wires and putting
together an office I don't love that
process I love the result because I'm
believing in entrepreneurs but I don't
know the process and so if you write
down you make a list of all the things
that you do the activities that you have
done that you've enjoyed the result make
a list of 10 to 15 times you've helped
somebody with that same pain that you
had growing up
you've helped them and you enjoyed the
end result and then Circle the wines
where you enjoyed the process as well
because when you can enjoy the process
and you enjoy the end result it's a home
run
now you've found your higher purpose now
you have clarity now you have a plan
that's the point of the purpose planner
step one you figure out your who your
one word most important core value step
two you figure out your why your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
never want anybody to ever have to
experience again because it was so
painful for you and then step three is
the how the process you need to love the
process successful people don't make
excuses successful people don't complain
if you look at whoever you want to look
up to look at the most successful people
in the world in any industry look at the
top and look at how much they complain
they don't complain when you complain
when you blame something else when it's
the government's fault or interest rates
fault or the bad economies fall or your
partner who screwed you over or the
customers who don't care as long as you
can blame somebody else right the
education system your parents your
friends your upbringing there's always
somebody else to blame and when you
blame somebody else when you're in that
mindset
then you never grow you're making things
easy on yourself
it allows you to Coast it allows you to
play Live super safe because it's not
your fault that you're not more
successful of course it's not your fault
that would be difficult that would be
hard it's somebody else's fault so you
can just stay where you are because
people are holding you back from
accomplishing the thing that you want to
accomplish we're successful people
take responsibility for where they are
in life and they say I don't care about
the government I don't care who's
President I don't care about regulations
that you have or things that you're
holding me back on I will still go out
and get mine
and of course there are other factors
of course the country you come from
matters of course education you had and
and the connections you had growing up
of course it matters
but so what you have to play the hand
that you're dealt you have these cards
you have to play those cards and you can
have success one of the things I love
looking at and this is why I do all
these profiles is a successful famous
entrepreneurs there is always somebody
who has done way more than you have done
with way fewer resources than you
already have so no matter what terrible
situation that you have and I'm
empathetic
maybe you had come from a broken home
maybe you have a really severe
disability that's physically holding you
back from doing some of the things you
want to do you know maybe there's a lot
of pressure on you maybe you have some
disease maybe you have zero money in
your bank account these are real
pressures and I'm empathetic to that
but so what
the longer you believe that those things
are gonna hold you where you are then
they will
there are people
who have worse conditions less money are
in worse situations and they came out of
it and accomplished amazing things
because they believed that they could
and if somebody looks like you has gone
on and accomplished big things then you
can too
and it only happens when you accept
responsibility for where you are in life
life isn't fair
the family you're born into the country
you're born into your religion your skin
color your gender there's a lot of very
real things that exist in this world a
lot of very real prejudices that hold
people back life isn't fair and chances
are you might not have the capital or
the education or the resources or the
parents of the family or the connections
or the right skin color or the right
gender or any of these things you might
not have it all lined up for you
perfectly and so the next step is then
what do you respond to
so yes you're right and then what
are you gonna be like what most people
do is they just complain they complain
that life isn't fair they complain that
they don't have the right circumstances
and then they become a victim of those
circumstances or are you going to take
the more difficult path the one of
taking personal responsibility personal
accountability and choosing excellence
and saying I'm gonna break free of this
mold I'm gonna break free of the
circumstances that were placed above me
I'm gonna set my own path I'm Gonna Make
the World better for myself and the
people around me I'm gonna choose
Excellence if you look at the people
that you love the people you look up to
the people that I profiled on this
channel whoever your heroes are Your
Role Models the people you aspire to be
chances are they came from nothing
chances are they had tons of odds
stacked against them and they chose
excellence and that's why they won look
at Michelle Obama her father was an
employee at a city water plant her
mother was a secretary and then once she
had kids was a stay-at-home mom so
Michelle Obama is the daughter of a city
water plant employee and secretary
turned stay-at-home mom and chances are
again whoever you look up to they have a
similar story it's very very very rare
and I've covered lots of these people I
may have covered more than anybody
online I've covered lots of successful
people it's very very very rare
that the son or daughter of a great
person goes on to do great things
themselves it's very rare that the kids
of people who've done amazing things go
on to do amazing things themselves it's
very rare it doesn't happen that often
and you might think that sounds crazy
these kids of super successful people
have everything lined up for them have
the money the education the resources
all the time in the world everything
handed them on silver platter it's so
easy for them to win
and that's why they don't win because
you win through the struggle because you
win by overcoming the Yachts because
that's how you develop Excellence by
going after the difficult things the
people who have an easy life never win
the people who have a hard life and
overcome and choose excellence and drive
daily and refuse to be a victim of those
circumstances those are the people who
ultimately win and so that's you right
now if you've you feel like the world is
unfair first of all you're right and
second there's a there's a bunch of
things that are stacked against you
then I would highly highly highly
encourage you
to surround yourself with the stories of
people who have made it with the stories
of people who look like you who have the
same background as you who have the same
circumstances as you who made it because
if they could make it then you can too
and most of the people that I profiled
most of the people have done videos on
this channel look at their stories
chances are they came from a worse
upbringing than what you have right now
they had less than what you have right
now when they started and one of my
favorite stories is Oprah Winfrey and
she was so poor growing up you know she
grew up without parents she grew up
being abused by her family she grew up
with her grandmother who had no money
and put together dresses made out of
potato bags can you imagine going to
school in a potato bag that was sewn
into a dress like how the ridicule would
be from your classmates at school
wearing a potato bag as a dress to
school can you imagine that and look
what Oprah went on to do
are you gonna tell me that you have a
worse upbringing than what Oprah had
or any of your Heroes
spend the time don't look at how
Michelle Obama or Oprah win for any of
these people make an extra million
dollars right now spend the time to look
at their backstory spend the time to
understand where they came from and when
they chose excellence and how it had a
massive difference and change of
trajectory of their life
because if they could do it you can too
you just have to decide
that one life isn't fair and that's okay
and two I'm gonna choose Excellence I'm
gonna stop being a victim of my
circumstances and I decide to make
things better for myself for my
community and for the people around me
you have the power to control your world
how you think how you act your mindset
with the words that you speak when you
use weak language you signal to yourself
that you are weak you signal to yourself
that your goals aren't important you
signal to yourself that you are not
worth it you lose respect for yourself
and the people around you don't respect
you either we need to stop using weak
language and pay attention to the words
that you're speaking to others and to
yourself now this is not an easy task
because most of the words that you're
using the way that you talk to others
into yourself you're on autopilot you're
on cruise control it just happens you've
been doing this for years or decades and
so switching it is not going to happen
overnight but if you pay attention to
the next three things that I'm gonna
share with you you can have a dramatic
impact on your self-confidence on the
goals that you have for yourself and on
the outcomes you create for yourself in
the world let's do it number one I I
can't I'm not I don't what you say after
those three things shapes your identity
it speaks to how you think and speak
about yourself so I can't I can't be an
entrepreneur I can't be a leader I can't
be a YouTuber I can't I can't I can't I
can't I can't especially this one when
you say I can't pay very very very very
very very very close attention to what
follows and try and try and try to shift
it from I can't to either I choose not
to or I can't yet I'm not I'm not a good
salesperson I'm not funny I'm not the
kind of person who follows through again
pay close attention and try to shift it
to not yet I don't
I don't program I don't know how to make
money I don't think like that switch I
don't to I don't yet I can't I'm not I
don't those statements are final those
statements don't allow for growth those
statements are how you feel about
yourself and don't allow for the stretch
they don't allow you to get better and
so either eliminate them from your
vocabulary or change them to yet number
two is catch your cruise control the way
that you have been speaking about
yourself the way that you have been
talking to yourself has been happening
using the same words for years maybe
even decades it's so automatic for you
you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard on yourself this is so ingrained
these patterns have been around for so
long you are just Auto defaulting to
cruise control that most of these times
you will not even catch it you will not
catch 99 of these moments of these words
of these languages that you're using for
yourself but if you have the awareness
if they have the intention if you have
the desire every now and then you will
catch it another quick hack is to enlist
the friend enlist the people around you
your wife your husband your team your
kids kids especially my son Hayden loves
calling me out on things enlist their
help tell them this is where I want to
play a bigger game this is where I'm
frustrated with myself this is where I
keep talking badly about myself and
putting myself down these are the words
the language that need to change and
every time you hear me talking this way
I need you to bring it to my awareness
and let me know because I want to catch
my cruise control for me personally it's
around complaining anytime I complain I
want my wife I want my team I want my
son I want the people around me to say
Evan you are complaining right there
that was a complaint eat it right I'm
happy for them to hug me with it to yell
at me with it I just want them to let me
know now when I told everybody they said
listen you you barely complain you're
like the least complaining person that
we know awesome thank you I'm humbled
but I still complain and I probably
complain a lot and a lot of the times
I'm missing it and so please please
please please please please please
please please please even if you think
I'm great at it if you catch me
complaining I want you to call me out on
it so enlisting your friends can be
really helpful because you will likely
not catch most of them yourself but it's
imperative that you start working on
catching your cruise control step number
three is manual override you have caught
your cruise control you have found the
autopilot it's about to happen again
this negative talk that you're about to
speak out into the world about yourself
or your ideas you putting yourself down
is about to come out again or has just
come out what do you do about it because
this is really important if you catch
yourself playing smaller talking
negatively about yourself if you catch
it and you don't do anything it actually
makes it worse it's better that you
don't even catch it at all if you catch
it and you recognize I am playing small
right now and you ignore it and you
don't change your behavior you are
building that identity for yourself that
you are somebody who is playing small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it it makes it worse
where when you do catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it what do you do you need to kick
your manual override into action and
take the action that you want because
that starts building the positive habit
that starts building the positive
respect this is how you build respect
for yourself this is how you start
building the muscle this isn't just a
zero-sum game this isn't just we go back
to neutral when you catch it you either
go sliding down or you go propelling up
the choice is yours when you catch
yourself playing small when you catch
yourself coming off of cruise control
you have to do the thing that builds the
self-respect up and speak positively
about yourself and do the thing that you
are scared to do
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there planning doesn't count planning
strategizing making ideas that doesn't
count where you're gonna grow it doesn't
count you gotta do you got to send an
email you gotta make a piece of content
you gotta post something you gotta
follow up with somebody you have to
create you got to make